hello everyone and welcome to the round
end game you've all been waiting for
it's round seven of the creation
Grantchester being played in Zagreb it's
yummy pony versus magnus carlsen and as
we've mentioned a few times I believe
during the coverage of this event Magnus
Carlsen was has never defeated nipple in
classical time time format so I believe
they've drawn five times in the nipple
beat cross and four times but Magnus
hasn't you know I've been able to win
even a single game so without further
ado let's just check it out the nipple
has the white pieces and he opens with E
4 we have C 5 Michaelson with the
Sicilian defense Knight to f3 Knight to
c6 offering to go into his well famous
especially cause this is what he plays
now against the e4 and here tonight the
c3 neppo decides to go for a closed
Sicilian with 'if I've by Crossin he's
not you know a stranger to such
structures with Bishop to c4 and now g6
preparing to being kept the dark square
bishop and it's a very similar game
maxy maxy photograph played a similar
line against Carlsen in the sinful cup
of 2018 and he started with h4 right
away but it it kind of transposes later
again into that game but not really so
but but it's a very similar line so here
nipple goes d3 instead not h4 right away
and only after Carlsen plays h6 he goes
h4 so right away he wants to push h5 and
create some weaknesses on the Kings side
cross and goes d6 and now we have h5
with g5 by crossing and not nice to h2
and there was a there is a similar game
that went this way but the night went to
d2 and then to f1 and at the e3 but will
basically get the same position so and
none of this is basically a new move so
Bishop to g7 causing continuous
development nice to g4 now heading for
III Knight G to e7 and here we have
Knights to e3 and here
Bishop to e6 is a known move in this
position but here after cross and castle
do we have a completely new game already
as a move 10 so very exciting never
continues
Bishop to b2 and now King to HH you
don't want your King on this diagonal
and now comes g4 by nipple we've roped
the b8 by Magnus and now a for
preventing b5 of course and now Knight
to d4 by Magnus since well it's such a
lovely square for the knight black white
at the moment doesn't have a piece to
oppose it and since the nipple already
pushed for an G for this really weakens
the f3 square only the queen guards it
at the moment so if the Queen should
move could be it could be very dangerous
so Knights eat the d5 nipper also brings
a knight into the center of the board
now as cross and also pushed both c5 n
e5 nipple has a very nice outpost on d5
for his Knight so calls and eliminates
one of them with Knight captures Knight
captures and now Knight back to e6 the
f4 square is also a very nice outpost
now Magnus wants to go there with the
night with f3 by nipple and now Knight
to f4 and here Napo will either capture
this night at some point probably not
with the night as the position being
closed you will prefer nice over bishops
here but first Queen to be one is now
the Queen no longer needs to guard the
f3 pawn nepo now goes Queen to be one he
wants to play Queen to a2 and perhaps
even Castle queenside with Bishop to e6
by Magnus Magnusson also doesn't want to
trade nights you wanna he wants to trade
his light square bishop for this night
at some point not right away of course
nipple continues with his plan with
Queen to a2 and now comes Queen to d7
and here already you have to be careful
if you continue for example with a slow
move like a 5 or something then you have
to watch out for tactics like Bishop
captures than g4 and here black would
have a lot of compensation you're
already threatening checkmate
and after you prevent this let's say you
capture the night you're gonna go eat
captures on f4 you're gonna free the
bishop here and you have a lot of
compensation here for your piece you can
go f3 there are already a lot of a lot
of threats here in the position so after
Queen d7 we look to g1 nipple guards the
g4 pawn and now just b6 Magnus continues
to play now if a 5 then this then even
b5 can be played so not a problem
rush of the c3 pineapple and only now
does Magnus trade in the center with
Bishop captures Bishop captures and a6
now slowly but surely preparing the
expansion on the Queen side now he wants
to push b5 never goes Bishop back to be
to like Magnus he also wants to grab
this night at some point you don't want
to leave this well such a powerful night
here on f4 for the ax for the entire
game with Queen to e7 by Magnus and now
comes looked f1 with b5 by Magnus now
opening up the Queen side captures
captures and now well neppo has to
decide how how to go about this position
you could try Queen to a7 offer a queen
trade but first he wants to get his King
to a safer Square so first King to f2
now he's probably gonna go King g3 maybe
bring it over to h2 or maybe just leave
it on g3 it's perfectly safe there and
it's gonna well serve as additional
protection to the pawns and here Carlson
had some an hour and thirty minutes on
the clock whereas nipple had only 38
minutes on the clock so here after some
consideration Carlsen continued with c4
and it's really a wonderful line he's
offering not one point he's actually
offering a lot of pawns here
so nepo has to decide does he wanna
accept the challenge or does he want to
trade down with a bunch of characters in
f4 if you accept the challenge something
like bomb characters pawn captures and
Bishop captures then Carlson has a lot
of resources at his disposal even for
the price of this one pawn but you can
continue sacrificing even more points d5
and if Bishop captures now f5 and black
just goes all out the white king is now
not looking all that safe a knife - and
well even though white is up material
you don't I don't know it doesn't feel
like all that the great of a position to
be and if you're if you're playing white
so nipple doesn't like this he doesn't
accept the challenge he plays Bishop
captures on f4 he says I'm not
interested in any of your sneaky you
know alpha zero inspired attacks I'm
just gonna capture here get rid of your
monster night on f4 with he captures on
f4 but of course by eliminating the
monster night you also freeing out the
monster bishop
you know you can have it both ways and
here rook eight d1 by nipple the problem
is a rook F the d1 losses on the spot to
f5 f5 is really strong here if you move
the rook from the F file because well
for example you don't want to capture
with the Jeep on but if you capture with
the e pawn it's still no it's no better
Bishop to b4 check is coming and after
King to f1 Queen e3 and well there are
so many threats here you will you simply
lose here so never goes rook a to d1
keeping this rook on the F file and well
now there's more protection to the D
file but Carlsen plays f5 nonetheless
just just pushes f5 and it's a it's
really a wonderful move where you really
should consider capturing he captures an
f5 and allowing this Queen to III check
and you for example after Queen III
check King g2 you don't really have all
that many attacking options here as all
of your pawns on the Kings that are
still intact the bishop nicely defends
everything here after Queen e2 check you
can run away to h3
for example if captures captures and
everything is nicely protected here
you'll just keep away the Queen and the
game continues
the problem for nepo is that he didn't
play it captures on f5 he played G
captures on f5 but unfortunately for him
and this isn't the best way to treat the
position so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find the best move for
black in the position well I give you a
couple of seconds didn't prepare any
water unfortunately but for those of you
who are able to do it from graduations
you have just beat nipple for the first
time in your life and for those who just
want to enjoy the show here Magnus plays
g4 and now you see that there are so
many threats here g3 is a threat G
captures an f3 is a threat Queen to h4
check is a is a threat
Bishop to d4 check is a threat and you
simply can't prevent all them never
played d4 to prevent the Bishop from
infiltrating with Bishop to b4 check but
even if yeah if you play rook h1 to
prevent Queen from infiltrating with
Queen h4 you're just gonna get Bishop d4
check and after King F 1 G captures on
f3 and you're you're just gonna
you're just gonna lose here very quickly
there's not much you can do here Bishop
covers the G 1 square this is game over
so never play d4 he doesn't want to
allow Bishop to b4 check but now he
allows this infiltration with the Queen
Queen to a4 check h4 check with King to
e2 and here Queen to h2 check by Magnus
nipple blocked with the rook and here
Magnus played G captures on f3 with
check and in it was in this position in
fact unmoved 31 that Jana pony she
resigned the game and Magnus Carlsen has
defeated nipple for the first time in
his life so he resigned because there's
really nothing to do here if you capture
left or the rook of course is pinned if
you capture with the Kingdom Queen
captures here you just lose the rook
here so it's game over if you don't if
you try and run away but you also have
to keep an eye on this rook so you have
to play King e1 just protect the rook
then Queen g1 check is coming and again
you have to move the King you're going
to lose this rook and again you fall
apart if you block with the rook Queen
e3 it's just mate this is you know such
a such a beautiful mate already on move
33 that it's well it's unbelievable but
yeah I'm sure
Magnus was very happy about this and he
really out of nothing I mean okay
Napo decided to go for a close Sicilian
he didn't really try to attack or
anything and the Magnus out of a
seemingly peaceful position everything
was completely blocked off you know you
magnus eliminated the the monster knight
on d5 nip eliminated the monster I don't
f4 everything is you know fine and then
all of a sudden Magnus just played f5
and it was enough to enough the trick
nipple he he he captured with the wrong
pawn he missed I don't know what he
missed he missed Queen h4 check probably
but it's maybe if you've seen the live
coverage maybe we've checked the
interviews I didn't I didn't catch them
so you know if you have any additional
information feel free to share in the
comments but I just uh III knew that it
was different this was gonna be an
exciting game but this is definitely not
what I've expected but yeah it seems
like Magnus really really inspired by
all
four zero and his second Daniel dubov
and his well beautifully attacking games
so you know we can expect many more
beauties such as this one it would seem
Robert yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoy it I
would like to thank calm calm Connelly
and Clark Archer for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
in my previous video your thing go for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the well probably gonna cover
more games from round seven and then
we're gonna check out the standings but
it's pretty clear that Magnus is now
clear first after after round seven
oh yeah the once again I do hope you
enjoyed it and as usual you can check
two of my previous videos here thankful
for watching and yeah have an excellent
rest of your day